[Music]
all right let's go to Dallas Texas and
talk to Ando what's up
Andy hello what up how we doing hey hey
Dr John how are you I'm good what's
happening in your world ah so much you
know so much so much that sounds like so
much it is it's always so much right we
a break not always what's up um so my
husband and I have been married for
about 7 years and he's in his just for a
little perspective he's in his early 40s
and I'm in my
mid-30s and he's very spontaneous but
also a big worrier so he worries a lot
about everything and I'm kind of the
opposite so I like to plan and I'm I'm a
little more calm and um both of us went
to premarital counseling before we we
got married and neither of us have been
married in the past or had kids or
anything like that and we both agreed
that we wanted kids and ever since then
we've just been kind of missing The Mark
with one another and um this last
episode of
disagreement I don't know it just has me
thinking a lot and I'm I'm trying to
figure out I want to get some
perspective on our relationship
and see kind of where this is going end
up going in the future yeah that makes
sense so he's changed his
mind yeah yeah
well he was stuck on no for a while uh
we moved to a new area and um my yes
just kind of came up when we moved
because we were in a safe environment uh
which we kind of came from an
environment that wasn't really that safe
there was a lot of crime uh so we moved
to a new area safe environment lots of
kids lots of Peace we were in a good
place in our relationship and about two
years ago I I wrote him this nice
five-page letter that basically said
look I think this is a time and these
are all the reasons why and he said no
and uh I struggled with that for a while
and um I
eventually I guess got over my feelings
and um you didn't get over them you
buried them in the
yard convinced myself that I didn't want
them either you know I leaned into every
negative I could think of so you lied to
yourself in order to appease this dude
all right all right yes yes so hold and
then okay go ahead go ahead well this is
this is where it kind of comes to ah
head a a couple years later so now we're
talking in the today he calls me out of
the blue I'm at work he's at work and he
says honey I want a baby and I'm like
what
like for two years I've convinced myself
that I don't want them either so what
are you talking about and um he tells me
he does and I I you know I ask him all
the questions are you s are you sure are
you serious are you playing with me like
I don't understand what's happening so I
kind of want to understand how he's come
to this conclusion you know things like
that and he gets a call from his boss so
he had to let me go um but I texted him
and I said look I need to know if you're
being serious because I don't want to
let my mom
wander about this subject I need to know
and uh when we got I we both got home
from work we talked about it and he
assured me that he was sure and then
about a week later he changed his
mind um so once he said yes I started
getting excited and I started I started
doing my planning that I do and then it
was a no again and he can't tell me
why he can't tell me why he said yes you
can't tell me why he said no so I'm just
annoyed you're not annoyed that's not
true you're
devastated yeah yeah I am and I
something tells me that you're so afraid
to actually feel that because you know
what that actually
means so let's let's put baby aside
because baby is um that's a really heavy
topic uh or it's a lightning rod
topic this isn't the only only thing
that y'all have Push Pull in your
marriage your marriage isn't very good
right now is
it aside from this topic we're pretty
good I bet
not okay here's why here's why you don't
usually and it's not always the case but
you don't usually selectively
shove something this important
away in isolation by
itself okay this has the Hallmark of a
relationship where somebody is slowly
dying over a long period of time in
order to try to prop up this fantasy
that this my life is going to turn out
this certain
way
okay I can be totally
wrong you could be like no I'm I'm
totally open on all my needs everything
I want everything I need I I communicate
it he communicates back to me he tells
me the truth we're always we are inoo
except for this one
thing you would be I mean we are we are
pretty good um I will say that like for
me I know me and I've I've always been
very independent I've always been the um
the captain of my ship and when I got
with him I had to relinquish a lot of my
control um in our relationship did he
relinquish too so that y'all could
together co-pilot something
new uh on some things not on all name
them the couch
colors where we live where we live I was
a big Pusher for that because I was
tired of where we lived and there was
too much crime and I moved him far away
not far away about an hour away that's
not far away H okay I mean it's not
especially in Texas that's down the
street yeah yeah that's true that's how
I felt everything's down the street in
Texas
yeah so let's put all that
aside
okay is this marriage worth not having a
baby I think so
okay if that's the choice you
make then you have to grieve what you
wanted so bad and you have to grieve the
picture of the life you thought you were
going to have because if you're like
most people both men and women you've
already thought about like a potential
name or two you have a room in your
house that you've already
pre-imaging on what the the the
Thanksgiving meal would look like when
our kid came home from college and
brought their new love home and dad was
going to make it weird like you've have
these pictures in your head M and you're
going to have to grieve them because
they're gone
right and then you're have to make peace
with this guy that has been like yeah
cool no yeah oh yeah no no yeah well you
moved me an hour away so I'm taking this
thing from you're going to have to grie
you have be okay with
it I'm not saying you can't be good but
here's what you're gonna have to do that
most people Never Do In This
Moment the marriage you thought you had
is now over and you have to build
something new with him
okay because what y'all have been
working towards is some sort of
intellectual compromise on having a
child when it's safe when we have enough
money when you feel like it when you
feel like it I don't feel like it
anymore well I don't feel like it
anymore either I'm just going to make
myself believe that I now I do now we
you're GNA have to create a marriage
where we are not having a
child it's just us what is us picture
going to look like fast forward to being
60 what's your house going to look like
what's your Thanksgiving meal going to
look like
then pretty uh pretty empty probably
that that that could be the word you
want to use or it could be no since
we're not going to have kids it's going
to be full of neighborhood folks or it's
going to be we're we live in a college
town so we're going to have a bunch of
college students who don't have anywhere
to go I mean you're going to have to
backfill that and change that picture
and if you just say things like well
it's just going to be us too sitting
around a
table and you think at 60 I'm going to
hate him I'm going to hate him yeah you
need to have that conversation
now I agree yeah that's but here's thing
he's not going to
change okay you got seven years of data
that suggest
that and by the way I don't want any
more dads in the world who hem haul like
this I don't want any more dads in the
world that take their wives most prized
picture and just blow their nose in
it so if he's not all in on being a dad
and being a husband then cool man I I
mean I'm not going to force that I don't
want that I don't want someone we don't
need any more parents under
duress right I want men who are
sprinting to the responsibilities in the
extraordinary life that is
fatherhood and he's not doing that so
there we
go
yeah the least he can do is stop jerking
you around though I
agree I agree yeah that was
rough you can't use language because
it's not truthful it's not honest you
can't use language like it's really
frustrating no dude it was
apocalyptic Earth shattering for you
because he let you believe
oh yeah I felt like I was lied too yeah
well you were
100%
yeah you
were I think you have to grieve
that
okay what does that mean here's some
ways and practical ways you can grieve
that
um you can begin to draw a picture of
what that house is going to look like
when you're
60 you can write that imaginary child
that you have in your head that you've
had for a while you can write him a
letter and say I'm not going to get to
meet you but I'm going to go do this in
the world now that's
okay you can write down the things that
you had hoped would be true
and now are not going to be true but
write them down get them out of your
body put them on a piece of
paper I wanted X to be true but Y is
true and by the way this is a choice I'm
making I'm making this
choice right right and so there's some
ownership there too and by the way just
because you own it doesn't mean it's
going to feel good all the
time that's
okay my son had finals this morning and
I Che chose to miss most 95% of my
workout I got in a few minutes and I
missed some journaling time this morning
cuz I wanted to be the guy that dropped
him
off I didn't feel good I didn't want to
do that I Was Made Me running around all
over this town but I I chose to do that
thing how's the world I created that's
what I wanted it just came at a cost and
that cost didn't feel great but it was
right okay but here's here's the meta
here you can't
just
at some point you either got to make
peace with this is the
life the man I married to does not want
to have kids we agreed on it seven years
ago it's not going to
happen and by the way I don't want to
have I don't want to make a human with
somebody who is yeah oh no I don't know
I'm not gonna do that I'm not gonna
bring a child into
that I want to bring a child into a
world that Dad wants him so bad and by
the way fatherhood is an extraordinary
responsibility so I want a man who's
going to take it and own
it and so I got to grieve the the world
I thought I was going to have because
I'm not or you have to have a harder
conversation about am I going to stay in
this marriage or not and nobody can have
that conversation except for
you
nobody I know you're hoping for a
different Christmas this this year I'm
sorry you had for for a week there you
had a different different 2024 picture
in mind I'm
sorry the only place you can go is the
mirror what do you
want what do you
need what are you going to choose moving
forward